toutes les personnes qui viennent dire
non c'est pas possible là tu es dans tu
es dans le délire ça vient que nous
renforcer dans notre paranoïa
Florent babillote bonsoir
alors selon une étude du département de
la santé publique de Créteil 12 millions
de Français souffrent aujourd'hui d'une
pathologie mentale et 2 millions sont
atteints de troubles sévères mais au
risque d'enfoncer les malades dans la
détresse on en parle pas Florent vous
êtes schizophrène depuis l'adolescence
vous avez vécu la souffrance du malade
qui ne peut pas en parler et aujourd'hui
vous êtes sous traitement à vie vous
avez décidé de faire de votre maladie
une force et vous êtes devenu
aide-soignant en psychiatrie
extraordinaire maintenant je suis
content d'être redevenu normal entre
guillemets voilà vous nous raconter
votre histoire à 20h
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Florent Robert vous êtes né le 24
juillet 1980 à Vitry-sur-Seine père
colonel dans l'armée de terre ce qui
suppose de nombreux déménagements au gré
des mutations de votre papa tout à fait
votre mère femme au foyer alors vous
avez une enfance bucolique et heureuse à
Vernon dans l'Eure scolarité sans
problème hélas cette innocence ne dure
pas vers 13 ans vous commencez à
souffrir de période d'anxiété quelque
chose qui vous fait penser que le monde
autour de vous n'est hypocrisie
quelque chose qui devient vite quelqu'un
une voix étrangement proche de la vôtre
mais en plus grave alors au début
effectivement il y a la raison qui me
dit non c'est pas possible ce que tu
entends c'est impossible donc problème
c'est qu'au bout d'un moment la maladie
la crise prenne le pas et on finit par y
croire comme c'est des voix qui viennent
de façon répétée alors cette voix vous
dit il te veulent il te cherche alors
vous essayez évidemment de résister de
vous raisonner mais ça revient sans
arrêt ça taraude votre esprit alors vous
êtes trop jeune pour comprendre ce qui
vous arrive vous cachez dans votre
chambre vous dormez pas à ce moment-là
vous n'en parlez à personne chez moi
j'ai peur d'être pris pour un pour un
fou totalement et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que comme les crises au
début vers 13-14 ans sont courtes je les
oublis rapidement c'est à dire que je
fais deux trois crises par an après ça
va beaucoup mieux et au bout de six mois
j'ai oublié que j'avais eu ce passage là
de crise pour moi c'était c'était rentré
dans une forme de normalité en fait même
plus compte
hélas les choses ne vont pas s'arranger
au fil du temps les crises deviennent de
plus en plus fréquentes et de plus en
plus longues et la voix devient
familière je l'ai appelé l'autre cette
voix alors vous dites dans ces moments
de crise la réalité ne change pas c'est
l'interprétation qu'on en fait qui est
biaisée c'est comme si à l'intérieur de
moi il y avait une autre personne qui
voyait le mal partout tout à fait c'est
comme des crises de paranoïaques par
exemple si à la police qui patrouille
même si j'ai rien à me reprocher je
crois qu'il me cherche devient numéro 1
on s'invente un personnage en fait donc
comme il vous voit
vous demandez ça il vous disent il y a
quelque chose qui va pas et là ça
justifie voilà toutes les personnes qui
va nous dire non c'est pas possible là
tu es dans tu es dans le délire ça vient
que nous renforcer dans notre paranoïa
on pensait que son complice voilà je
pense qu'ils sont complices
alors vos parents à l'époque ne se
doutent de rien le manque de sommeil
vous rend irritable mais vos parents
pensent que c'est parce que vous êtes un
ado quoi avec les ados c'est pénible on
pense que c'est la oui la crise de
l'adolescence tout à fait alors faisait
même une petite copine à l'époque ça se
passe très bien jusqu'au moment où la
voir reprend le dessus en fait et là de
l'autre côté dans votre monde à vous
vous êtes convaincu être l'ennemi public
numéro 1 rechercher par toutes les
polices du monde en fait c'est elle est
très loin c'est à dire que j'ai cru par
exemple dans le métro à Rennes qui avait
un agent secret qui était là en fait
pour me pister qui me suivait partout
donc je changeais station de métro pour
voir s'il était toujours là alors ce qui
est paradoxal c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose de grisant en fait à ressentir ça
vous dites du coup lorsque je
redescendais j'étais déçu de constater
ma normalité c'est que quand vous êtes
avec l'agence secrète dans le métro vous
êtes un héros poursuivi par un agent
secret mais quand l'agent secret s'en va
l'amour devenez voilà ce que vous êtes
en fait cette maladie là c'est aussi
ceci le fait que j'étais pas satisfait à
l'époque de ma condition sociale donc
voilà c'est je me suis inventé un
personnage alors à 18 ans vous êtes en
terminale vous vous préparez au
baccalauréat lorsque votre père part en
voyage au Brésil et là vous persuadez
que votre père a une famille cachée au
Brésil et qu'il va abandonner sa famille
française c'est-à-dire vous votre mère
et vos frères et soeurs pour aller
s'installer là-bas et en pensant que
donc mon papa a trouvé ma mère alors
qu'il n'en était rien mais je m'étais
inventé ça en fait au retour de votre
père du Brésil donc il y a un dîner à la
maison vous êtes là avec votre petite
amie votre maman a fait à manger soudain
vous regardez votre père dans les yeux
vous voyez rouge vous lui sautez dessus
en fait et vous lui dites à vous que tu
as une famille au Brésil je le prends
par les épaules je secoue très
violemment en fait quoi et donc toute la
famille se regroupe autour de nous pour
nous séparer en fait et je vois je
verrai toujours ce regard de mon papa
qui est terrorisé par son fils quoi ça
c'est un truc qui
vous n'oublierez jamais
pire quoi c'est vraiment un moment
très très dur pour moi et encore
aujourd'hui quand j'en parle j'ai du mal
quoi voilà alors là vos parents
effectivement ce jour-là découvrent
votre maladie le choc est terrible pour
eux terrible pour eux évidemment parce
qu'ils le savait pas en fait oui et puis
je sais que mes parents
ma mère elle a à cet inscrite à des
groupes de paroles comme une femme pour
justement essayer de comprendre mon père
aussi et ça leur a fait très mal au
début et j'ai voulu justement leur
montrer que on pouvait s'en sortir et
grâce à ma famille j'ai réussi à m'en
sortir et grâce aussi au fait que
quelqu'un de très positif c'est ce qui
m'a aussi sauvé quoi alors là vos
parents vous amènent chez un psychiatre
le psychiatre vous dit est-ce que vous
entendez des voix vous n'y est mais le
médecin n'est pas dupe et vous êtes
hospitalisé en urgence dans une unité de
soins psychiatriques à l'hôpital
Guillaume Régnier à Rennes vous acceptez
assez facilement je voyais bien qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui tournait par an
et je me dis bon bah maintenant que la
famille est au courant autant aller de
l'avant et essayer de se faire soigner
quoi en arrivant à l'hôpital vous
réclamez votre copine vous dites si je
la vois pas je me suicide et là on vous
met dans une unité fermée je pensais
qu'on voulait ne me séparer de ma copine
en fait et que et je me souviens d'un
passage très violent ou je crois que mon
portable est sur table d'écoute que je
suis écouté je prends le portable dans
l'unité fermée dans ma chambre je le
balance par terre je l'expose quoi enfin
j'étais fou quoi
alors voilà pas de copine donc vous êtes
enfermé là les to be vous font dormir 24
heures sur 24 ensuite il baisse les
doses il change les molécules et
finalement ça va mieux oui ça commence à
aller mieux au bout de au bout de
quelques temps c'est vrai que je suis
quelqu'un de très sportif et ce qui m'a
marqué c'est avant de d'être internet
j'arrivais à faire une cinquantaine de
pompes quoi et deux jours après j'ai
essayé je faisais deux pompes et je
m'effondrai enfin complètement et ça ça
m'a déprimé quand même et au bout de
quelques temps ça a été mieux parce
qu'il est traitements indignés donc j'ai
dormi moins et comme étant quelqu'un
d'hyperactif je supportais pas c'était
de dormir tout le temps de passer ses
journées à rien faire ça me déprime
encore plus et finalement au bout de
plusieurs semaines j'ai dormi moins donc
le moral est revenu vous commencez à
sortir dans le jardin de l'hôpital avec
vos parents et là vous vous mettez à
écrire et vous découvrez qu'en fait
vous supportez pas la normalité et que
cette frustration à nourri vos délires
ça vous comprenez ce que vous avez à ce
moment-là c'est c'est oui ça a été le
déclic donc cette voix intérieure en
fait elle compensait votre frustration
exactement j'étais un élève normal mais
je possède deux à trois fois plus que la
moyenne mais j'avais des notes normales
donc j'étais très frustré en fait je
voulais faire quelque chose de très bien
mais je n'y arrivais pas je préfère de
la psychanalyse à deux balles c'est pas
mon métier mais est-ce que c'est pas dû
à l'importance de votre père ça veut pas
être colonel dans l'armée quand même
c'est pas rien c'est pas faux ce que
vous dites parce qu'il y avait ce côté
en fait
vouloir lui montrer que je pouvais aussi
faire aussi bien que et il y avait comme
un complexe un peu d'infériorité
finalement c'est normal alors voilà vous
ressortez relativement rapidement de
cette internement vous restez sous
traitement et puis après une tentative
pour bosser comme téléopérateur qui se
passe pas bien en fait parce que vous
avez des problèmes de concentration
c'était presque un soulagement d'arrêter
en fait voilà vous reprenez vos études
vous décrochez une capacité en droit
avec mention bien parce qu'à cause de
votre maladie vous n'aviez pas pu passer
le bac vous entamez votre première année
en droit ça se passe super bien et là le
médecin décide d'arrêter le traitement
je suis ce qu'on m'a dit quoi et c'est
vrai que je referai jamais oui
aux gens d'ailleurs c'est qui ont la
même maladie c'est continuer le
traitement parce que on s'arrête ça va
pas c'est un des messages que vous
faites passer ici ce soir quand vous
arrêtez le traitement les délires
reviennent vous croyez que dans toute la
fac on ne parle que de vous chaque fois
que vous croisez un regard vous le
trouvez malveillant vous bousculez un
jeune homme dans la rue parce que vous
croyez qu'il se moque de vous enfin
voilà quoi c'est vous vous êtes là
dedans et puis un jour dans un bus qui
va à la fac vous avez un flash et ça
c'est terrible vous voyez votre père
mort alors qu'est-ce que vous faites
vous descendez du bus vous rentrez chez
vous en courant en fait trois kilomètres
en courant vous arrivez chez vous vous
voyez votre père souriant qui vous dit à
tu es là c'est un moment que j'oublierai
jamais parce que quand je suis arrivé et
que j'ai vu que mon père était bien
vivant c'est vrai que c'est un moment
qui restera jamais gravé parce que pour
moi c'était il était mort et le
lendemain j'ai cru avoir fait un
cauchemar pour vous dire à quel point
j'étais dans un cauchemar on sait pas
dans quelle réalité on est voilà je
savais plus du tout c'était vraiment et
c'est vraiment une vision d'horreur je
te dis à personne parce que c'est
j'étais très content qu'on percevivant
mais le passage avant cette image c'est
horrible voilà alors résultat maintenant
vous prendrez des médicaments à vie
alors après cette rechute vous décidez
de vous reprendre en main vous faites
une formation d'aide-soignant en psy
et là vous vous retrouvez ce qui est
incroyable dans l'hôpital vous aviez été
interné à Guillaume Régnier à Rennes
donc c'est vrai que le premier jour ça
m'a fait vraiment bizarre j'ai eu besoin
de m'asseoir quand même parce que déjà
il y avait une aide-soignante qui était
là à l'époque où j'avais été à internet
donc j'avais un petit peu peur du regard
il y avait des personnes qui étaient
encore interdiques a vu les mêmes soucis
que moi et là ça m'a fait bizarre je me
suis dit je pourrais encore y être en
fait quoi vous devez avoir un lien très
spécial avec les malades de l'hôpital
vous savez ce dont il souffle forcément
ça on a on a une empathie qui est très
développée vu que on a vécu les choses
donc on et puis on peut anticiper
certaines choses c'est à dire que une
personne qui qui va faire une crise ça
marche pas à tous les coups mais on va
avoir un ressenti différent vous êtes
heureux aujourd'hui je suis très heureux
j'ai essayé de faire de ma maladie une
force une force créative je suis sur
d'autres projets de d'écriture encore et
j'essaye de donner un message d'espoir
et dire on peut s'en sortir et
schizophrène super merci merci de votre
témoignage et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu